à droite le cfm56 actuellement le plus
puissant réacteurs d'avion à gauche le
premier propre fils jean 90 un énorme
engin de trois mètres 12 de diamètre
l'équivalent du fuselage d'une caravelle
au cours des premiers tests sur le tout
nouveau banc d'essai de la sté cma une
poussée de 50 tonnes a été atteinte la
puissance maximum de six tgv ensemble ce
moteur construit en coopération avec
l'américain general electric est
entièrement nouveau moins gourmand en
carburant meilleure fiabilité
il sera aussi moins polluants avec
déroger assez faible d'oxygène azote et
de monoxyde de carbone ce nouveau
réacteur est destiné en premier aux
futurs boeing 777 qui volera dans un an
ce sera le plus gros bimoteur du monde à
peine plus petit que le jumbo 747
ensuite le jei 90 équipes râle airbus a
ici que ceci sans un cadre et réacteur 2
600 à 800 places
mais cet avion ne volera pas avant l'an
2000 si ce futur très gros porteur a
déjà presque ses moteurs on est loin
d'avoir résolu tous les problèmes et en
particulier ceux liés à la sécurité